okay everyone
uh welcome to the ddps seminar uh
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk
unless you have questions if you
have questions you are welcome to unmute
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q and a session at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences so
no classified discussion is allowed
watch out finally the talk today will be
recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an
honor to host rui wang who is a
second year computer science ph.d
student at uc san diego
advised by professor rose yu
he obtained his master's degree in data
science at
north eastern university and bachelor's
degree in mathematics from
zhong university of science and
technology
his research interests are in spatial
temporal learning and
physics guided deep learning
okay today rui will present an exciting
topic which is
physics guided deep learning for
dynamics
forecasting please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk from louis
now without further ado let me pass the
button
to rui by asking one random question as
usual
since it is friday today in order to
recommend
a movie for the weekend today's random
question is
um what is your favorite movie rui
my favorite movie uh i think
the uh revengers oh okay
i like that movie too yeah okay
thank you so much okay it's all your
three
okay okay
hello everybody um i'm marie
so hello everybody i'm ray i'm a new
summer intern
uh at the machining group supervised by
brenda
and my mentor is fed so yeah currently
i'm a phd student at
uh in the special temple learning group
at east san diego otherwise by professor
rosu
so you can see here is the logo on our
lab
so you can see there is s and t and rows
in it so
generally our group works on deploying
optimization
and special temporal reasoning for me i
focus on physics guide deep learning
which i'm going to talk about talk about
today
so so today i will uh talk about my
recent works
about this physics guide departing for
the names forecasting
so first i will talk about like what is
the physics guide deep learning
and discuss what are the motivations and
goals of it
then i'll give a very example uh show
how prefix knowledge can be incorporated
into different models
to do turbulence uh prediction
so even though deep learning is capable
of learning very complex dynamic systems
so we need to think about the
generalization problem in forecasting
uh which is a key challenge for
deploying to learning dynamics
so to improve transition with deep
learning
i i will finally provide two ways um so
the first one is
to incorporate uh symmetry into dpr
models to design equity models
the other one is leveraging math
learning techniques
so you know modeling the special
temporal dynamics
is a fundamental task in engineering and
science
so phases has the long traditional use
uh first principle-based model uh
models to uh like describe the dynamics
and many physics laws are encoded into
systems of
nonlinear pdes that have the direct
implication
for understanding and predicting the
dynamics
but this equations i sometimes based on
radial assumptions and it
can be too complicated to be solvable
and numerically solve this equivalence
require so much computation
and manual engineering in each
application
on the other hand deep learning i use
statistical inference and deadline
methods
which provide a much faster way to learn
the dynamics
but deep learning is still a black box
so it can generate
a very realistic prediction but in
consistent with the physics laws
and also deep learning struggle with the
generalization
um it cannot cope with additional
discriminator shift that may naturally
occur in dynamical systems
so there is a growing need to integrate
uh prefix knowledge or physics-based
modeling
into deep learning so that we can take
the best from both time methods
so by encoding a profits knowledge as
inductive bias into deploying models
we would expect the model will have
better physical consistency
uh require fewer samples during training
and the general is better to anything
domain and eventually will increase the
trust
in ai
so first i will talk about the paper in
which we use the deep learning to
model the evolution of turbulence and
accelerate the simulation
so i'll show how practice knowledge can
be easily incorporated into different
models
to make a physically meaningful
prediction
so a little bit about the background the
turbulence modeling is a fundamental
task in science
such as mesopotamic science marine
science and aerodynamics
turbulent flows iconic dynamics that
occurs over a wide range
space and time scales and the current
cfd
like technique requires so much
computation so that's that's why
in this paper we study task of
turbulence prediction with deep learning
so basically you want to have a robust
dp model that can
uh like make for accurate forward
prediction giving the historical
velocity
fields so the data like
we use in this paper is is is running
beneath convection
if you look at this video you can see
it's a 2d case
the top radial is the velocity along x
direction
the bottom one is velocity along y
so uh basically is a horizontal layer of
fluid
from below so the temperature at the
lower surface is the higher the
temperature
at the upper surface so this the
difference in the temperature cause this
can
come back to emotions so in this paper
we propose a physics guide
model turbulence net uh turbulence
turbulent flow net or tfnet
that unify a numerical method with a
customer design unit
we will show our model the predictions
from our model
are not only accurate but also
physically meaningful
the turbulence is governed by number of
story credence
and since we were doing incompressible
flow so if you
if you look at the first equation you
can see the divergence the velocity is
zero
um so people uh usually we might to
fully uh what
we might want to fully resolve this
network agreements with the direct
number of
simulation um that would resolve all the
skills
all the civics and time scales of
turbulence but in that case
it requires so much computation so
people start to use
all kinds of spatial and temporal
filters to decompose the velocity into
large scale component and small single
component so that
we can directly simulate the large
scales and
model small ones for example large eddy
simulation
which uses a spatial filter to decompose
the
velocity into a large scale component
component and a fluctuation component
another another example is a rounded
average method
which basically did a similar thing but
with a temporary filter
to measure the time average quantities
so
it's natural to combine both with which
leads to this
hybrid resonance coupling method so we
first apply
this spiral filter to decompose w to w
star and double prime
then apply this temperature filter to
decompose w star to w bar and w tilde
so finally we will have this three level
decomposition
over the spectrum domain so if you look
at this figure
on the if you look at this figure
at the bottom right so here the y-axis
is the energy
and the x-axis is the wave number so
basically the small wave number
corresponds to large eddies and the
large wave number correspond to
small a so this basically this figure
shows how energy transform
from large scale components to small
eddies
so in this method method like a speeder
filter works like a standard uh
convolution kernel and the temperature
filter is like a weighted moving average
so people usually predefine both filters
but in our model
we set both filters at trainable
parameters
okay here is the overall architecture of
our model
you can see so at first so we first
apply
like both the trainable spatial and
temporal filters
to decompose the input velocity field
into three
components so then we pass the three
components
to three identical encoder and one
shared decoder
and each decoder encoded in the decoder
can be viewed as a small unit
each encoder is supposed to model the
evolution of each component
and the shared decoder is supposed to
learn the interaction
among those three components and
generate the final prediction
so the intuition behind this is like
inspired by this
uh less coupling method we try to force
the dp model to learn all the secure
components
uh because um because if we directly
train the model
on the data the model may um a bit like
with the
msc loss the monomer just only focus on
the large scale component
and overlook these small eddies
and also apart from this we also try to
constrain the training process of this
tf net
because the data we use is
incompressible flow so the divergence
is supposed to be zero so we can
strengthen the training of tf.net with
this
divergence fury loss so to say to see if
we can further improve the
performance we we refer this version of
tfn as
constrained tfn since our task is very
similar to the video prediction task
so we compare for the experiments we
compare our model with six space lines
including three uh iconic four period
data driven video production models and
the two physical scanner models
so here this video shows the prediction
uh like on the velocity u so it contains
the ground truth and prediction from the
tf net
and three are three best baselines
so if you look at the prediction based
on the shape of the eddies and the
frequency
you can see the prediction from our
model much closer to target than
baselines
since another goal is to um like speed
up the simulation so we also measured
every time to generate a single velocity
field
um so you can see the first bar plot the
first part is
lbm which is the largest lattice poisson
method
that we use to generate the data set so
and uh so based on this popular we can
see that there are inference pfnet unit
again
it's much faster than the numerical
method
so the reason why the speed up is not
very significant because
the the lbn method we use to do the
simulation
is already highly up highly optimized to
the numbers to occurrence on gpu
so it's not very fair to compare but we
believe the neural nets will achieve
much
like a bigger advantage of speed for
higher resolution and higher dimensional
data
we also evaluated our models prediction
um
two physics matrix so the first one is
divergence
you can see this plot shows the mean
absolute divergence versus the focusing
horizon
so the blue line is the uh tf net and
the orange line is the constraint
you can see uh the uh the tfn always
achieve the low uh the lowest divergence
uh like at any prediction step and
canceling it with divergence rate loss
can further improve its performance
so and we also embedded our model uh
modulus on this energy spectrum
so i can see this the black line
is the uh the ground truth and the two
dollars
two theoretical lines and the blue line
is still the tf net
you can see the tfn is still closer
target
than other baselines
to demonstrate actual damage to
demonstrate that armor actually learned
the multiscape behaviors
so we also did an ablation starting so
that is
um uh so you can see in this video in
this video
this video contains the like ground
truth prediction from tfnet
and the outpost of each unit in our tf
net
while zero are the other two encoders
you can see the temporal unit temporal
part um
encoder can generate a very steady flow
and the fluctuation fluctuation one have
like
through some the movement of small
eddies and the special one is showing
something between these two frequencies
so based on this average study um
actually we can demonstrate our model
actually learn the
multiple behaviors and then share
decoders
can learn the linear combination of
different components
so in summary um we see improved
prediction
accuracy and physical consistency by
incorporating prefix knowledge
and physics-based modeling into deep
learning
but to actually have a very robust model
for
dynamics forecasting we still need to
spend more effort starting the
transition
ability of deep learning so because
transition is a fundamental change in
machine learning the prediction
performance usually degrades with the
distributorship
uh the test set to achieve a
good production performance we usually
need a lot of data
to train the model the training set is
supposed to have
very good uniform coverage over the data
from different domains or different
tasks
a fundamental difficulty of forecast
forecasting dynamics
is that the discriminant shift that may
naturally occur in dynamical systems
so uh in this lucky learning for dynamic
control paper
based on some uh like experiments on
synthetic data and the real world
coin19 data so basically we have one
we observed that depending models fail
to learn the correct dynamics
when there is there is distribution
either in the data
domain or the parameters the systems so
the distributed shift in data can be for
example like the change
of the orientation of the flows or the
changes in the scaling
and the the parameters like here
the distribution of interpreter for
example can it can be
the change of initial and boundary
conditions so
to improve the transition ability of
bipolar models and
for for dynamics forecasting basically
we provide two ways
to improve the generalization so the
first one
is to incorporate symmetries into
different models
to design accurate models so basically
in this paper
we propose to improve the prediction uh
performance and the
transitionability of deeper models by
incorporating symmetry
so because by designing a model that
inherited equivalent
variant to the transformation of the
input the model would automatically rise
across these transformations
and more importantly no notice will also
give us
a correspondence between like
the conservative quantities and the
symmetries for example the rotation
correspond to the conservation of
angular momentum uh the translation
correspond to the conservation
of energy so
in this paper of the symmetry we started
including
rotation uniform motion and scaling
since they all have very different
properties so we
employ a variety of methods each
tailored to enforce different symmetry
we will show the equivalent model we
designed
will significantly outperform the
non-inquiry models on both
very vanilla convection data as well as
the real world ocean dynamics
okay i'll first quickly uh go over a few
um
definitions so uh suppose like here
we have a function f and a group g so
a g equivalent means f of g x equal to g
f of x that means apply this uh grouped
uh the the transformation j to x
equivalent to apply the transformation
to f of
x and the corresponding g value means f
of g x equal to
f x so in this paper we only focus on
the developing
accurate models this figure um
uh this figure like yesterday the
example uh function f
that is are equivalent to the patients
so
uh you can you can see like you're
rotating the input f
by 45 degrees uh like the output of the
f4 will also be
like rotated by 45 degrees
when we said and where clg is a
symmetric group of different currents
that means if j preserve the solution
different uh uh different occurrence for
example if the
velocity w is solution of an average
occurrence then
energy for example rotation group the w
is also a solution of different cranes
so in this so in this very process we
are trying to model the forward approach
function f
we should map the historical velocity to
the next step
and uh and if the g is the symmetry
group with
the number stoic cranes and then the f
is supposed to uh like equivalent to any
transformation from the group j
for flow dynamic there is actually five
different symmetries including
space translation times translation
rotation and information
as well as the scaling in this paper
since we are
we focus on the convolutional net it's
already
equivalent to space translation and as
soon as we
use the model or autoregressively to
make the forward prediction
it should also be time translation
equivalent so
so in this paper we only focus on the
following three uh symmetry
rotation uniform motion and scaling
so the key to building accurate models
is that the composition will accurate
function is accurate so as long as make
sure
every layer is accurate then the whole
uranus will be equivalent
so first look at the scaling equivalence
so scaling equivalence for fluid
dynamics is
quite unique because you can say it is
related to the
magnitude the space and time like
simultaneously so this is very different
from the scaling
uh like image that is only regarding the
about the resolution so
um so we know the standard conclusion of
cross correlation
uh is like a translating kernel
uh site over at the input w
actually this can be written in more
general form which is group correlation
so h is a relevant group and the lq is a
group action on
x on the uh w
so it has a very good properties so it
has a equivalent and
actions of group h so applying uh
like so the q axon w is equivalent to qx
on the
output the convolution of the between uh
kernel psi and the w
so uh so that so this this is why the
standard convolution is accurate to the
uh translation so to to achieve second
equivalence so we directly incorporate
this
like a scaling transformation laws into
this group correlation layers
so that is we upgrade uh the standard
conversion
with the group quotient later layers so
in which
we both translate as getting a kernel
across the input
so here is the equation so it looks
um quite complicated so you can put it
away
if you only look at this like the figure
at the right bottom basically
in each layer we apply sim kernel
to the input upscaled and downscaled
by different scanning factor lambda
based on the screen transformation law
and we are concatenate of this uh the
multiple compose a
multiple outpost and give it to the next
layer
but in the practical since the input
data can be
really large so instead of perform
screen transformation to the input
we perform a screen transformation to
the kernels because upskilling
the input is equivalent equivalent to
the um downside to kernels
so basically each layer we apply
like here we will apply the same input
with the kernels upscaling and
downscaling with the various scaling
factor
lambda um so that's that's how we
achieve scaling and equivalence um
but the only drawback of this method is
that
it's it'll be slower than a standard
convolution because
you need to compute multiple uh
convolution in each layer
for for the rotation experience
so to you it's also quite unique because
now we are dealing with the vector uh
field so
uh so like we know we should we should
not only rotate the position of vectors
but also the direction of the vectors
to to incorporate rotational equivalence
so we designed
group equivalent kernels so in
in taekwohn's paper they defined the
group the j-account kernels which map a
special location
to a feature vector has to satisfy this
kernel constraint
so so you can see here the key is kernel
and our g can be any uh can be a
rotation and the row can be any uh like
a representation
which map at the abstract element to a
general linear space
so basically the the group j and the
choice of the representation determines
the form of the kernels
so for example you can use trivia
trimmer extension should map every good
rotation to identity
function then the kernel would be k of
gx equal to q
over x so in this case the kernel would
become a composition of
circles with different radii and each
circle the battery should be the same
but this but in this case the kernel
would be over
the reference type representative power
of the newness will be uh over a
constraint
so we can also try the robot station
which map
every group element to a rotation matrix
so in this case each entry in the kernel
would become a rotation matrix
um but in based on experiments and on
particle we actually use
the regular representation of the cyclic
group in our middle layers
so regular abstraction feature field
associated with a feature vector that
have the
same dimensionality as the order of the
groups
for example for example here so this
this is for example here the c4 group
which model
models the rotations by the multiples of
pi over two
and the circular group acts via the
permutation axis so you can see
the regular reputation of a c4 group map
each rotation
to a permutation matrix
so since it's just a permutation like
like
axises so in this case you can always
use
any uh element wise on your function
so based on our experiments uh this uh
like a
regular representation of secondary
group gave us the best performance
so the last uh symmetry is uniform
motion experience
which which is adding a constant vector
to the vector field
to achieve uniformity at q variance
actually um we have we have this uh
like correlation in our paper uh
basically
it means if we like you force every
layer to be
rotation uniform motion and covariant by
composing constraint to the kernels
um the uranus can only be a fine
transformation
so instead of like constraining the
kernel we
actually use a very simple trick that is
convolution calculated by the average
operation
so for basically for every um
like here the convolution we first find
the mean of the input
and shift shift it to the uh like the
velocity
field that is a zero mean and
apply any convolutional linear functions
and shift the mean back
so by doing this we can easily achieve a
new formation equivalent
because the uniform motion
transformation always have a canonical
frame
so but we cannot use this approach for
the other two symmetries
because we didn't know there's no
canonical skill orientations of the
fluid flow
um for experiments we test our model uh
on both the synthetic rbc data as well
as the ocean current dynamics
so if you look at this video uh
you can see basically the videos of the
ground gratitude prediction from the
non-current models and liquid models
on the test sampled on test samples
applied with the transformation from
random
group so more specifically you can if
you look at the first
column which is target so this the first
one
is like original test sample added by a
random
consonant vector and this one is the
original test sample
rotated by a 90 degree and here
the this one is the original test sample
uh obscured by
uh skinning factor three so you can see
the equivalent models can automatically
generalize or cause this uh random
transformations from relevant group
but the non-commodore cannot do that
so here here's the production
realization on the ocean
car dynamics you can see here is the
target
and here is the net and the three
equivalence net so from this prediction
realization you can see
that uh the proteins from acquiring
models having more uh a closer target
contain more details um okay
yeah it's also like here so because like
it's equivalent
so it is more simple efficient so you
can find more prediction realization
or i like your results in our paper and
um we also show why like equivalence is
a better option than
like a data augmentation technique
so since our essentially study like in
this paper is uh
quite pervasive so we expect our models
can
be why applicable to many physical
physics problems
so in summary so in summary we see that
our incorporating symmetries into
different models
can improve the transition and the
physical consistency
so apart from making models equivalent
to the
like the relevant group we also propose
um
model-based meta-learning techniques to
like
make the model be able to generalize
their course like a larger heterogeneous
domain
so like here you also so usually like a
new model must be trained to make
forecast
for specific systems and uh when
like when this is like when the model is
applied we applied to a
system with different initial condition
bar recognition
or any different system of parameters
the model would fail
so for example if you look at this like
this figure it shows two fluid flow uh
these two flow
fluid fluid flow are governed by exact
semicredits
and they have the exact same initial
condition set up
the only thing that is different here is
the bonus
point avoid forces so you can see the
bottom one
has a like uh uh bigger like a point
avoid
uh forces uh so it is more turbulent
so usually people like we need two
separate models to train on
each of this uh fluid flow
so it's very it's imperative to to
develop a generalizable models
can learn a predictive way
over a large heterogeneous domain so
that's why we propose like this paper
uh model-based method techniques
so so same as before we aim to learn
function
up forward place function and our model
actually
is inspired the fact that similar
systems may share
uh time invariant features and we also
assume the large domain
can be partitioned into a separate
subdomains
and each society associated with a task
so here a task refers to
forecasting a specific system given a
set of parameters
so the general idea here is that
we first want to have an encoder or like
a method learner
that can uh infer the task specific
information
uh given the input with this minimal
supervision
and we also we can't have a generator or
forecaster that can
perform conditional reasoning based on
this timely variation features
started by this encoder so more
specifically here
is the over architectural model
basically
the model we name our model as diet so
you can see
the dye is learned the dynamics in two
stage
it has two parts one encoder and decoder
so the encoder is supposed to map a
different
like dynamical systems into a time
shift invariant feature z-c with the
like a week's provision of task
parameter c
so the test parameter c here can be any
can be like constant motions initial
conditional boundary conditions
or whatever that can characterize the
system
then the eu coder can perform
conditional reasoning based on
the like inefficient feature learned
from the encoder
and the previous previous system states
to make accurate forward prediction
so as long as the encoder or the meta
learner is trained well so
the forecaster is about supposed to able
to make accurate prediction
and accurate um and quickly adapt to new
tasks that
never appeared in the training set
so how to train this encoder so we use
this loss function
so it has three terms so the first term
uses the week's provision of the task
parameters
whenever they are available so such
provision can guide
the decoder to learn the correct task
specific
uh like information um
but in reality not all the test
parameter not all the parameter systems
are known
so but we can compute the like
approximate values for c
uh like based on our domain knowledge
for example if we want to
want to model like multiple turbines
with different uh
points uh like buoyancy forces uh
we don't need to actually use the real
bonus effective factor
we instead we can actually use the um
can directly compute the average
velocity or uh verticity
from data as a circuit for task
parameter c
another example could be oh we try to
like forecast
uh the system temperature over a large
area of the pacific ocean
we can first divide this large area to
sub-domains
and uh it should be associated with a
task and here let's see we can use the
like the mean temperature or even the
season
so the second term is like called the
time
shifting variance loss so we should
penalize
the changes in changes in the latent
variables between
samples from different time steps so
because we want to design a time
evaluating coder even though we already
use uh
like a convert3d as encoder but it's
just approximately time shifting variant
so this loss can even drive the time
shifting loss even lower
the third term is to prevent the encoder
generating very small
small z because because of the time
shipping very low
and also can encourage the model to
learn more interesting
hidden features easy so after the
encoder is trained
so we can uh we eject this like to learn
hidden
features into the forecaster using
adaptive
stabilization and adaptive padding so
and every adaptation is no matching is
while using uh style transfer
uh like models basically it to use
it just to rescale like every channel
in the convolution with the learned
feature
and we also here use adaptive padding uh
which
is so in the forecaster instead of
padding zero we're padding the linear
transformation and learn the filter fcc
so for experiments we basically
compare uh our model uh with a series
baseline on three different
data sets so turbulent flows sea surface
temperature
and real world ocean current uh current
dynamics
so we compare our model with the series
baselines including
like video prediction model like pretty
iron as well as the
metal learning models like mammal and
the magnet so basically we test
a comparative models on two test
scenarios so the first one
is like dynamics with different initial
conditions
which correspond to this future test set
this
this matter the capability model to
extrapolate to the future
on the same task so the second the test
set
is the domain headset basically we test
all the model
uh the data with different system
parameters
or like the like a different areas on
the scene
so we want to model to estimate the like
a model's capability
to uh learn the new tasks so you can see
based on
like this like the numbers in this table
you can see
so no matter we use the rest net or unet
as our forecaster
the performance always outperform these
like baselines
for the ocean current dynamics we also
measure these like
the energy spectrum errors you can see
the our model image
achieve lower and the spectral errors
so that means our the model is even like
physically more accurate so
here is some like prediction realization
um so on the turbulent flows
so this figure basically shows the
ground truth prediction about two best
uh baselines in our model and different
time step of
prediction for turbulent flows so on the
left is likely flows with one is factor
nine
on the right is the bonus factor uh 21.
so you can see the our model can easily
generate per accurate prediction
for different flows but the base lines
have trouble understanding and just
tangling the buoyancy factors
to further demonstrate our model
actually learn like the encoder actually
learn the useful information
we also did like a controllable forecast
so the figure on the right shows the
outputs from our model
while we vary the encoder input but fix
the forecaster input fixed
so from the left to right the encoder is
fed with the flow with different points
factor
5 15 and 25 and the prediction and work
input
always have fixed points factor 15. so
if you look at the first column so
when the encoder is fed very stationary
flow
the prediction from the forecaster also
generates a very uh
stationary flow and when we feed this
encoder with a very turbulent
fluid flow that is very turbulent then
the prediction
from forecaster is also very turbulent
uh you can find more like prediction
realization and therefore
in our paper so basically so we can use
so in summary we show that we uh by
using
maternity like techniques we can uh have
a model that
that is able to generate a course over a
large heterogeneous domain
so um basically that's all i'm talk
about today uh so
in summary we see in the ekf net
turbulent flow net we replace the
mathematical like uh
temporal filters with the trainable
weights
so then the model is able to generate
very physically accurate predictions
and we also uh like incorporate
symmetries design crew models
so the acrylic model is able to uh able
to obey the conservation laws and
general journals to
different data transformations so
we also like how we can use method in
dynamics forecasting is task as
inference
for the future work um i would like to
explore more about this
theoretical analysis because the
theories for
forecasting now non-stationary and
chaotic dynamics is still missing
current theory is limited still based on
limiting to to the id assumption
um so i think we need to have a bond
like jonathan
that can can can be
uh repressed in terms of like the
characteristic systems like
the stability of the older the pds
um that will help us to better
understand the um like here that
the performance depending on learning
dynamical systems
and another promising style would be uh
give the dynamics
um how can we design environment control
it
and another like a promise step i think
would be
uh starting the cause of causal infra
difference in
dynamics so for example how to uh use a
causative to improve the
different models for example uh
uh so for example so we won't try to
have like a
have a robust model for kubernetes
dynamics forecasting how to make sure
the model always gives the correct
response uh like
given different interventions
so yeah that's all what uh that's all i
think that's all i want to talk about
today
thank you very much for listening thank
you so much
rui it was a wonderful talk um
okay um so let's have a q and a session
we do have a one question from xia long
he asked on page 14 how do you determine
the lambda
sorry page 14.
this is p14 this one
that's 15. this this lambda right
i think so yeah so that that's a very
good question because the skinny group
is like a place it's comparative group
so
so in practice you see it's not possible
to model
all the lambda so in practice we use
like
seven different lambda from one over
three to three
so so all they like to so in that case
the model would be approximately scale
equivalence yeah
okay so it would be case dependence
right and then
for different problems how do you um
i mean determine the range of lambda
um in the first case they're first
um i mean i guess you determine the
range of lambda for different problems
so i guess that that is like your
problem dependent and
also uh based on like decapitation so
if you use too many lambda then the
model will be
quite slow uh so yeah i think i would
say
that that the choice of lambda is only
depend on the problem and
and i think you need to try like in the
experiments
okay got it it would be great if this
lambda could be adaptive
uh yes problems thank you
okay okay um so i don't see any other
questions
from uh from the uh the chat room but i
do have a question
um so
that it is very promising i and i i i
love the i
love to hear your methods
today especially the the third one
i was very interested in you know die at
the meta learning dynamics
by the way um all the the numerical
results you have reported
um whether it was either the comparison
between the image
and or uh roon means square error but
sometimes the rooming square error is
kind of misleading because that depends
on the
actual the data value so have you
computed the relative error instead of
the uh rooming square error
um right no but um
no actually no but i think that's a
good advice so because uh yeah i i
agree with you so that's why we also
evaluate the prediction based on the
end response the spectrum error so
that's basically their target and it's
the difference between the target and
the spectrum and the
and the the energy spectrum of the for
the prediction so
basically this energy spectrum errors
can
like show whether the models position
actually capture the
distribution of the physical systems
okay that sounds good and another uh
measure
um you know as uh
the the scientific machine learning
uh community is really interested in
is the speed up um do you
yeah but but i i haven't seen any speed
of results
yeah but i i i believe you will get a
lot of speed up right
yes uh so basically in the first
paper we actually compare uh
the speed sorry
so right here so basically this plot
it shows the like uh the every time to
generate a single
velocity field you can see there are
three models your inference
is much faster so the reason why the
speed up
is not very significant because this lbm
method is already
serious highly optimized to navigate
currents on gpu
but and also we are still i'm we are
working on like a 3d turbulence
so i would say the speed up is more even
worse
it's much more significant and promising
okay all right um
um well i don't see any other questions
so i i guess i can ask
one other question i mean if you guys
have a question please
um mute yourself um ask questions or put
that
put that in the uh the chat room so we
can address that questions
okay so my next question is um
so you you've been uh focusing on you
know
you know using using the data of
some temporal data and then try to
extrapolate uh
to the longer period period of
this the predicting the longest longer
um
temporal solutions right how about
um you know just trained
you know get the training data for some
specific
uh the parameter uh set like it could be
mach number it could be
something right uh material property um
and then try to perturb those um you
know
parameter and then try to predict with
the
with the machine learning uh have you
how can you extend your method to that
framework and
uh so you do that how would you do that
yeah
perturb um so like
if we if i currently think if you only
train the model
uh a specific system it will have
trouble to generalize to a different
system like a system with a production
because um because deep learning is
failed to
like deal with the distribution shift um
so that's why
we suggest like here mattering
techniques
in the end so we need to so the diet
so basically we need to train the model
over uh like different uh like here many
different systems
so as long as we train the method well
the model is supposed to like him like
to the system never appeared in the
train set yeah
so that's my answer yeah
okay um
is there any other questions from
audience
hi great yeah great talk um sort of
question
uh regarding the simply stuff um so
um how much
saving you uh gaps uh
in terms of you know using data
augmentation with us um
using synthetics basically
uh i'm sorry i could say that again you
mean
yeah i mean amount of training data
that's required
uh by using you know uh documentation
versus uh using symmetry uh
explicitly oh
so oh i see so actually you can't find
that
result in the paper so basically uh
uh i think we i think yeah equivalence
remodel with the
uh i think addrem will be much faster
than the augmentee test
technique because you uh so
if you use that augmentation you need to
augment a large amount of data
and you're going to need a much bigger
like
model so like you uh we didn't
actually show uh measure the like uh the
inference time
like we didn't show in the paper but we
do show
like acronym models like make more
accurate prediction
more physically accurate prediction than
data augmentation techniques
um so i think apart from this
the scaling equivalence the other two
acquired models was much faster than
this automation techniques um
so yeah so the drawback of this skinny
occurrence is still like it
could be slower than the like a standard
convolution
i have another question okay um so you
you know
um lstn the long shot
memory network yeah it sounds like
that's that's a perfect candidate for
your uh your methods
to apply um
uh you mean convolutional stem
yeah long short term uh yeah yeah we
tried it
it's one of our baseline the tf and the
paper
oh you did oh okay so i i missed this
okay any other questions
i know alicia asked me about the
recording and the recording will be
available in the youtube channel
and i i did as a matter of fact
share that link in the chat and let me
do that again
and the uh ruiz today's talk
will be available in this youtube
channel or playlist
in the future near future so
please check that out
is there any other questions
no thank you i had a question
thank you it's a very this is tom
edmunds thank you it's a very
interesting talk
um so you're measuring the accuracy of
your models in terms of you know these
micro scale
measurements of the fluid flow but have
you looked at
some kind of macro scale measurements
like for example how much
heat is flowing to a surface to you know
see how
see how much improvement you get with
your models
yeah that's a good question actually we
didn't
but i think that's be um
that's a good advice yeah yeah i think
yeah we didn't
uh do that in the paper
sorry hello hi roy uh this is so raj can
i ask a question
sure sure oh yeah so i mean like you
were comparing like
energy spectrum for your prediction are
you also like using
that energy spectrum as like a
regularized loss function
during your training or no oh yes that's
a great question actually we try
try to using the energy spectrum as a
regularizer
but we we found that it didn't help
improve the production performance of
the model
okay
okay any other questions well these are
the good questions
so
well if yeah it looks like
we don't have any more question okay so
please but but
i mean please do not hesitate to reach
out to
uh rui directly i'm sure rui is a
nice enough uh if you email him he's
going to
uh you know respond to your email and
also i i hope that this the seminar
will initiate the future collaboration
uh between you
the audience and the louie so um
please take advantage of it okay uh
thank you so much we it was really
interesting to talk
um i learned a lot um personally
and uh yeah thank you so much
um and we will add
on here and we have another ddps seminar
next week so
please stay tuned
okay let's have sean